well eduardo is eleven and eight with a
five eras facing the mets for the first
time in his career he's got a 413 obp
that is strike three
94 to punch him out isn't that nice
punches that one toward the hole
iglesias throws and damn he made a
really nice play off balance
fading back into the outfield had
someone to throw it's amazing how he
went after that ball he didn't cut
across he let that ball get to him for a
marcus an outstanding year his last game
a six innings pitch two runs a walk and
eight k's so now it's devers with two
out and a man on
he drives this one down to right field
and conforto is there to grab it and
that retires the side
lonzo leads off
and waved out and missed and a good
change up to strike him out oh
back-to-back change-ups that was
dynamite
very first base he'll be
taken off and in there strike three
came back to phantom
he has struck out five over three
iglesias to leap things off here
scoreless in the third inning
so that's crank down that's a fair ball
that's going to reach the corner
near the 310 marker he's into second
with a stand up double
and an eight-game hitting streak for
jose
red sox had the bases loaded and nobody
out here in the third inning
yeah that's pulled on the ground down to
third davis coming home for one throw to
first by neato in time for the five two
three double play beautifully executed
and strowman gets two outs
runners move up to second and third for
rafael devers
and that one's popped up
could be playable in comes pilar and he
makes the catch and strowman gets
himself out of big time trouble in the
third and lindor is on for the lead off
wall abby baez has been on base 14
straight games
hits that ball hard through the hall of
base hit just got it past bogarts
lindor pulls in at second so in a no two
pitch baez
gets himself a base in and the mets have
the first two men on ahead of alonso
the mets of the base is loaded with
nobody out eighth pitch of the at-bat
coming from rodriguez to davis
and jd takes it low ball four and the
mets grab the lead
third walk of the inning for eduardo
rodriguez that forces in lindora with
the first run of the game
and it's one nothing new york so a run
is in bases remain loaded for michael
conforto
and conforto grounds one that'll go
right through the hole and in the left
center for a base hit baez scores alonso
trying to score the throw of the plate
in plenty of time alonzo tries to get
around the tag but vasquez got him for
the out
it's an rbi single for michael conforto
two nothing new york hard sin to
understand i mean nobody knows fenway
better than gary d sarcina who grew up
in in massachusetts
everybody's playing shallow that's right
because of the wall in left field
so a runner at second for vasquez a
grounded up pitcher to first
[Applause]
[Music]
boy you never see
that guy do that no first step that
first reed step cost him because that
ball was smoked by vasquez
another pitch to hit and he didn't he
didn't miss it it's a double for the
door met some runners at second and
third red sox will make a pitching
change brazier comes on to try and hold
them and feel leaning in
cut out and miss the other mind striking
out
bae is down
hacking away for out number two
[Music]
[Applause]
good work here by brazier to keep this
thing two to one
so the bottom half of the fifth keiki
hernandez will get his third look at
strollman tonight he's
[Applause]
swinging a high fly ball up center
that's it deep that's way way up there
it is gone
[Applause]
hernandez with number 18 and he has tied
the game 2-2 well i tell you he give him
something upstairs it's a high sinker
what a mistake home run double to start
this inning and how the momentum has
changed in a hurry
shot out to left center that one high
that one deep and that ball is gone
boy have things changed in a hurry home
run double home run by bogey another
high sinker leads to ballpark what an
easy swing by bogey we've seen a lot of
this
from him lately his 23rd how about that
pretty swing
i mean there's nothing but beauty in
that swing
now the bases are loaded for boston that
sacks with a chance to really bust it
open with xander coming up
and he goes the other way for a base hit
iglesias in to score kk right behind him
big night for xander he has four rbis
red sox open it up six to two that's
like taking candy from a baby right
there have a night and it's not over yet
now we got richard who's done a dynamite
job since he's went out to the bullpen
got a save his last timeout
and he'll pop this up
iglesias
with the grab one down in the eighth
inning here's alonso for two on a walk
tonight
and the slider drilled toward the
monster that ball is out of here
a line drive home run off the bat of
people lonzo is 34th of the year to get
the mets closer it's now six to three
deep down in the count owen two and he
just hammered that ball up over the
monster seats for number 34. and we'll
get the bottom third of the order here
for the new york mets red sox trying to
beat them for the third time in three
meetings this season
roller toward first charged by dolbeck
quickly richards gets their one away
darwin is the fifth member of the pen to
pitch
[Music]
there's a shot out to left backing up
and making the catch
with
[Music]
red sox wins six in a row
they knock off the mets tonight
6-3 the final score
you